MARK MORGAN, THANKS SO MUCH FOR
YOUR PERSPECTIVE ON THAT ON
THAT.
>> YOU BET.
>> Tucker: A YOUNG PIONEER
ALEXANDRIA ACADIA CORTEZ IS A
MEMBER OF CONGRESS BUT WOULD
MAKE A FANTASTIC -- IF SHE
DECIDES TO CHANGE CAREERS.
IT'S NOT ENOUGH IF SHE DECIDES
TO OPPOSE THE PRESIDENT'S
IMMIGRATION POLICY, SHE ALSO
WANTS TO DESTROY ANYONE WHO IS
REMOTELY CONNECTED TO SECURING
THE BORDER.
WAYFARER IS PROVIDING BEDS FOR A
NEW IMMIGRANT HOLDING FACILITY
IN TEXAS.
TODAY, SOME EMPLOYEES WALKED OUT
IN PROTEST.
OCASIO-CORTEZ ENDORSED THEIR
EFFORTS, TWEETING "THIS IS WHAT
SOLIDARITY LOOKS LIKE."
THEY BE NEXT SHE WILL BOYCOTT
THE SNACK FOODS THAT I.C.E.
STOCKS IN VENDING MACHINES.
ELIZABETH WARREN IS ENTERING
TONIGHT'S DEBATE WITH A FRESH PO
TONIGHT'S DEBATE WITH A FRESH PA
TONIGHT'S DEBATE WITH A FRESH PL
TONIGHT'S DEBATE WITH A FRESH PT
TONIGHT'S DEBATE WITH A FRESH PO
COMPLETELY DECRIMINALIZE A
LEGAL BORDER CROSSINGS, WHICH IS
OF COURSE COMPLETELY INSANE.
SNEAKING INTO AMERICA ILLEGALLY
WOULD NO LONGER BE ILLEGAL.
WHAT WOULD HAPPEN TO THE COUNTRY
IF WE DID THAT?
MELISSA FRANCIS, COHOST OF
"OUTNUMBERED" AND "AFTER THE
BELL."
THANK YOU FOR COMING ON.
FIRST, ALEXANDRIA OCASIO-CORTEZ,
WHAT DO YOU MAKE OF THIS?
SHE IS SAYING THAT ANYBODY WHO
DOES BUSINESS WITH A I.C.E. IN
EFFECT SHOULD BE PUNISHED.
>> I MEAN, IT'S IDIOTIC.
THE CEO OF WAYFARER, A PUBLIC
COMPANY FIRST OF ALL.
THEY ARE LOSING MONEY.
THEIR CEO DOESN'T GET TO MAKE
DECISIONS LIKE THAT, HE HAS A
LEGAL RESPONSIBILITY TO DO BEST
WITH THE SHAREHOLDER'S MONEY, IT
IS NOT HIS MONEY, HE CAN'T MAKE
DECISIONS BASED ON HIS OWN
POLITICS OR HIS OWN DEFINITION
OF MORALITY.
HE HAS TO TRY TO MAKE MONEY FOR
HIS SHAREHOLDERS.
IT'S AGAINST THE LAW FOR HIM TO
DO WHAT SHE WANTS HIM TO DO, TO
TURN DOWN BUSINESS, ESPECIALLY
GIVEN THE FACT THAT THE COMPANY
IS LOSING MONEY.
LET'S TALK ABOUT
ELIZABETH WARREN AND THIS OTHER
PROPOSAL WE ARE GOING TO HEAR
MORE ABOUT TONIGHT AT THOSE
DEBATES, IF YOU DO AN, WHERE
THEY ARE SAYING IF YOU CROSS THE
BORDER, IT SHOULDN'T BE ILLEGAL.
GUESS WHAT.
IT SIMPLY IS COMING HERE TO SEEK
ASYLUM, IT'S BECAUSE THE RULE OF
ASYLUM, IT'S BECAUSE THE RULE OL
ASYLUM, IT'S BECAUSE THE RULE OW
ASYLUM, IT'S BECAUSE THE RULE OH
ASYLUM, IT'S BECAUSE THE RULE OO
ASYLUM, IT'S BECAUSE THE RULE OE
COUNTRY HAS BROKEN DOWN TO THE P
COUNTRY HAS BROKEN DOWN TO THE I
COUNTRY HAS BROKEN DOWN TO THE T
COUNTRY HAS BROKEN DOWN TO THE W
COUNTRY HAS BROKEN DOWN TO THE E
COUNTRY HAS BROKEN DOWN TO THE T
COUNTRY HAS BROKEN DOWN TO THE O
COUNTRY HAS BROKEN DOWN TO THE L
COUNTRY HAS BROKEN DOWN TO THE N
COUNTRY HAS BROKEN DOWN TO THE E
COUNTRY HAS BROKEN DOWN TO THE R
FEEL SAFE.
THEY COME TO THIS COUNTRY
BECAUSE THE RULE OF LAW WORKS
AND KEEPS THEM SAFE.
SO HOW IS BREAKING THE LAW
HELPING THOSE PEOPLE WHO ARE
COMING HERE FOR LAWS AND
SECURITY QUEST MARKET THESE ARE
BOTH REALLY STUPID IDEAS.
HOW DOES TAKING AWAY FURNITURE
HELP CHILDREN?
HOW DOES TAKING AWAY LAWS HELP
CHILDREN?
IT DOESN'T.
OUR LAWMAKERS HAVE MASSIVELY
FAILED US.
THIS IS A HUGE PROBLEM THAT IS
ENORMOUS.
BECAUSE IT HAS FESTERED FOR SO
LONG.
THERE IS NO EASY WAY TO SOLVE
IT.
IT'S GOING TO TAKE A WHOLE BUNCH
OF SOLUTIONS.
HERE'S THE THING, TUCKER, WHAT
IF EVERY TIME WE INTERVIEWED A
LAWMAKER, WHAT IF YOU WENT I
TOOK THIS PLEDGE AND EVERYBODY
ELSE, SHEP, SEAN, RACHEL,
ANDERSON, WHAT IF WE ALL SAID
THAT EVERY TIME YOU INTERVIEW A
LAWMAKER YOU SAY, NAME ONE THING
YOU HAVE PROPOSED BEFORE THAT
YOU ARE WILLING TO GIVE INPUT ON
THE TABLE AS A GESTURE TO GET
THE BALL ROLLING?
YOU CAN'T NAME WHAT YOU WANT IN
RETURN.
BECAUSE, YOU KNOW WHAT, EVERYONE
IS GOING TO HAVE TO WORK
TOGETHER TO COME TO A SOLUTION.
THAT PICTURE OF THE DEAD CHILD
IS REALLY HEARTBREAKING.
BUT EVERYBODY LOOKS AT IT AND
THEY SEE SOMEONE DIFFERENT TO
BLAME.
WE CAN ALL LOOK AT IT AND SEE
THAT IT IS A TOTAL FAILURE ON
THE PART OF AMERICANS.
LOOK AT THAT PICTURE AND ASKED
LAWMAKERS, WHAT IS IT THAT YOU
ARE WILLING TO PUT ON THE TABLE,
WITH NOTHING IN RETURN -- YOU
WON'T LOOK WEAK, YOU WILL LOOK
STRONG.
WHAT YOU THINK?
DON'T YOU THINK THAT WOULD WORK?
>> Tucker: IT MIGHT.
PERSONALLY, I THINK THAT THE
PEOPLE IN CHARGE OF THE COUNTRY
FIRST NEED TO CARE ABOUT A
COUNTRY.
I AM IN A COUNTRY NOW, JAPAN,
WHATEVER THEIR FLAWS, THE
LEADERS CARE ABOUT THE COUNTRY
OF JAPAN.
THERE IS NO IMMIGRATION TO JAPAN
BECAUSE THEY DON'T THINK IT IS
GOOD FOR THE COUNTRY.
THERE IS ALSO NO LITTER AND NO
CRIME.
EVERY PRIORITY ON BOTH SIDES OF
THE DIVIDE POLITICALLY, THE
BASIC PRIORITIES ARE THE SAME,
WHICH IS TAKE CARE OF THE
COUNTRY.
I DON'T SEE ANYONE IN CONGRESS
PUTTING LITERALLY AMERICA'S
INTEREST FIRST AT ALL.
>> I AGREE WITH YOU BUT I THINK
THIS WOULD EXPOSE THEM BECAUSE
BOTH SIDES HAVE LED THIS PROBLEM
FESTER AND IT HAS BECOME A GREAT
POLITICAL THING TO THEM, WAY TO
HIT THE OTHER SIDE.
I MEAN WHEN YOU HAVE SOMEBODY
PROPOSING THAT ANYBODY WHO COMES
INTO THIS COUNTRY ILLEGALLY IS
SUDDENLY ILLEGAL, THAT DOESN'T
MAKE ANY SENSE, SO THEY ARE
OBVIOUSLY NOT TRYING TO DO
ANYTHING REAL, THEY ARE TRYING
TO MAKE A POLITICAL POINT.
IT LETS CHALLENGE THEM TO